school systems across the country are
carefully watching the coronavirus
pandemic to see if their reopening plans
will hold up
online schooling begins this morning in
new york city
and teachers are predicting the worst
they're raising new concerns over safety
and sanitation
putting this monday's first day of
in-person
learning at risk nikki batiste is in
queens new york nikki didn't the
teachers make a deal with the city
to allow schools to reopen
anthony good morning yes they did just
two weeks ago on points like increased
testing for students and staff
supplies of ppe and safety upgrades to
buildings but as you can see from the
teachers rallying here this morning
they say it is still not enough new york
city schools are still not safe to
reopen
one told me her colleague passed away
from covid at the end of last school
year
and another just tested positive this
week
[Music]
teachers protests continued in new york
city tuesday
as educators warn their schools are not
ready
for students to return i am so nervous
i am really nervous and i know my family
is nervous
the teachers union says test turnaround
times are taking longer than the 24 to
48 hour period that was promised
teachers say their windows don't open
far enough or can't open at all
to provide adequate ventilation and some
say their cleaning supplies are already
running low
it gives me anxiety because it's the
unknown
we are ready we want to be with our
students but it's not
safe but the city says 98 percent of
teachers got their kova test back within
48 hours
and the mayor says most classrooms are
ready to go
the problems that have been raised about
individual classrooms for example
those are being resolved while the city
has promised an additional 2 thousand
teachers
to help with a blended learning plan
educators say
they need 10 thousand where we are is
not where we should be
based on the promises that were given to
us according to the new york city
department of education
42 percent of its 1.1 million students
will take all classes online that's up
from
26 percent more than a month ago but
distance learning has its own challenges
all classes are currently online in los
angeles county
but a survey conducted by the office of
education
found schools there need roughly 50 000
additional computers
and wi-fi hot spots to ensure their
students are adequately equipped
but adequate testing may not be a
problem for los angeles county public
schools
there is no other school district doing
this los angeles school superintendent
austin buettner was among the first to
be swabbed
during the official launch of the
estimated 150 million dollar testing
initiative
their goal is to run 40 000 tests on
students
staff and their families every day
hopefully getting our kids back to
school and keeping them safe
keeping our faculty safe keeping our
kids safe
in a statement to cbs news the new york
city department of education says it has
comprehensive protocols in place
to guarantee the health and safety of
all students and staff
including requiring social distancing
face coverings
and random testing tony no easy answers
here nikki thank you very much